bismillah alhamdulillah Salma can peace
be with you welcome to the Deen show
we're here every week with another
exciting episode spring and summer fun
is what people are anticipating getting
out of college getting out of school
summer break summer vacation we're going
to give you some really good tips to
make the best out of this summer so you
can stay out of trouble and have the
best time we'll be right back with those
incredible tips for you here on the D
show don't go nowhere
this is the thing
Salam alaikum welcome to the Deen show
come a little closer we're gonna
introduce you to our guests
Tom sure that's right with Sam Shareef
how are you I'm doing great today how
are you how's it going
been very good today up until now you
know what we people go to the Deen show
calm you have your own section there
they can watch some of the programs that
we've done in the past
God willing inshallah summertime is
rolling around Eid or to it looking
forward to it and some people you know
they take it all off and they just want
to have the greatest time in their life
because summers around we don't want to
get any trouble and the people that are
just going all out of bounds and then at
the end side effects anxiety you know
the depression medications are being you
know prescribed because all that fun led
to heartbreak and emotional trauma drama
so we want to give you know the viewing
audience some tips on how to really
enjoy this summer the wholesome way
people going back to organic food right
right we want to go back to the the
wholesome organic living what do you
think about this I'm really glad that
summer is coming up so my favorite time
of year I love the sunshine and all the
signs of God that are around you you get
to appreciate that one of the best ways
to appreciate that is to at least
acknowledge a creator so the first step
in it's a tip for all of our viewers
viewers last year your wardrobe try not
to make your wardrobe too new and what I
mean
you can buy new clothes but sometimes we
tend to push the envelope right it just
as a society last year I wore a
two-piece this year I might wear
something less or last year I looked
this way or I spoke to these I spoke to
these guys and girls this year I'm going
to push the envelope that's what we need
to be careful of during the summer times
so my first suggestion to everyone is
wear what you wore when you felt modest
not changing with the times it's one of
the most important things but this
summer is a usually it's a time when
people start heading out and they want
to show more of their bodies I think the
best thing that you pointed out was all
these medications that are being
prescribed they
do take an effect God give you a body
that was meant to be covered now you
someone would say but why that covering
came through with the book in the Quran
God said to draw your veils he told men
to lower their gazes when speaking to a
female did in a respectful way what
happens is when you start uncovering
those body parts it's literally if you
got it you flaunt it right that's how we
work here yeah if you keep flaunting you
won't have anything else to flaunt
you'll end up naked and that's where the
self-esteem gets killed and that's where
the person looks gorgeous from the
outside and I forgot how many plastic
surgeries that other it was happened
last year she had like 10 plastic
surgeries and Botox everything in a in
like a week span yeah it was one
specific person and at the end you still
don't look perfect because perfection is
forgot look the way that you are and it
won't just have to do with dress it'll
have to a lot to do with your self-image
this is amazing because we want to go
back to living a wholesome organic life
that is ordained by the one who created
us he knows best yes we don't know best
so we've come to this way of life using
our mind using the faculties that the
Creator has given us based on proof not
just emotion right so okay we realize
that the Quran is the verbatim word of
God Muhammad peace be upon him is a
messengers like Moses Abraham Jesus they
all came with the same message worship
the Creator not his creation and
establish your life around pleasing the
Creator the life I like you said that
your food your dress your action but but
one of the things that happens during
this summer it's summer blockbusters
right so we go to the movie theater we
try to get connected why not choose this
summer why not choose to make why not
choose to watch things that won't entice
you maybe things that aren't as sexually
perverse because in the beginning it was
just maybe one or two scenes but if we
keep watching people in our life dressed
a certain way we're gonna see that too
so Islam is about venerating or
worshipping our God but not just through
actions but through the daily life what
eat dress and on that organic push to
make things a little bit more pure
doesn't the Creator the same God of
Jesus of Moses Abraham the gone who
created everything doesn't he say in a
verbatim word of God successful are
those who purify
it so aren't we trying to purify our
heart and every time you look at
something that you shouldn't
pornographic images audio pornography
you listen you hear all of these
negative nasty things right doesn't that
affect the heart and rust the heart from
all these sins and that is the decay of
you in the Kay of society so we're
trying to not let our heart get
corrupted by watching what we see
watching what we eat watching what we
listen to
I want to answer no I say it doesn't
affect us at all I'm that guy at home
saying a bunch of crazy people yeah yeah
let me rock down that path if I watch
things that entice me to a natural
inclination if I watch something like
pornography something sexual your time
I'm trying to defend that it won't
affect me if I listen to music that
constantly has shake this shake that and
a woman moaning no that's not gonna
affect me either okay so if I spend the
entire day out looking at people that I
find attractive and I keep staring at
them is that not gonna affect me I think
this summer where we have a chance to
kind of scale back on even the things
that we do personally I'll take a quick
side tangent a pornography is a huge
issue not in Islam not just as a society
we tend to see things that are on movies
and then we want to reproduce them
whether it's an action scene or whether
it's something that would degrade
someone else the summer time is when
these new images are appealing to us so
I would say your movies pornography the
music that you listen to and even the
friends that you hang out with they
affect you and if you're a young person
who says it doesn't affect me then you
sound as it you sound as not intelligent
as I I sounded five minutes ago saying
that it doesn't change you at all so I
think what we need to do is is find out
what that limit is and that that's the
key phrase for today's show is no one's
gonna set that limit other than Allah
hmm he says in surah Baqarah in several
places in the Quran Allah Iike whom
Allah is on the people who find God and
the world that he's given us in the
hereafter to be better to be more
productive to work for to invest there
those are the people who have attained
felicity who have attained success so
the question
is not what you do but how much of it do
you do what's the limitation so some
people look at this is like man these
guys are extreme can we safely say that
many people just because out of
ignorance or many people because you're
adapted to the culture and society
they've extremely gone away from the
wholesome way so we're trying to
stimulate what's in the human being the
human being knows that moral compass
might be off but they know when they
hear they hear that look we're talking
about sex inside of marriage we're
talking about a man respecting a woman
not degrading her and treating her like
a piece of meat and the woman having
some self dignity that she's not just
wanting to get all that attention so
she's taking it all off
keep it on preserve yourself protect
yourself so what he comes on is I think
if we just look at America just the
people who are viewing this show 40
years ago when a guy and a girl wanted
to go out you approached her dad you
spoke to her and said I would like you
courted her just to go out what changed
our moral compass and I mean our because
we all live together were society what
changed our moral compass what pulled us
away it was did it was denying God's
Word whether it was a Bible Quran or
Torah everyone who wanted to become more
liberal cut away from what was deemed
God's Word to be man to be intellectual
to be rational
we cut what we thought was mystical and
then we went forward and said I'm gonna
define things on my own
so Allah in the Quran constantly tells
us liars though we as harbin re well
sabudana hmm there's no comparison
they're not equal the people of the
paradise and the people of Hell so let's
take that model here the people who
cheat steal the people who don't care
about society and hoard wealth they
might look perfect here in this world
but what will they pay for or what will
they be able to show face for on the day
of judgment and if you want an example
of that here when you see a billionaire
now giving money you feel like oh yeah
that's his responsibility because he was
D was ordained to have this so the same
way you're not gonna see a drug dealer
meet god drug dealer who killed and hurt
people
and pushed the envelope someone who
backed by date and kept talking about
gossip
that person who gets up and says well I
didn't think I was gonna affect anyone
you have to think about that so the
Islamic perspective the Quranic spur
spective is that organic is not just
food but organic is the human nature
when you follow that nature for example
if you pulled you change your clothes
off of your young child right and you
say shame shame or something they'll
cover themselves yes yes
it's natural right and I've just
discussed this yesterday as a closing
point a child will never respond to a
stimulus until an adult tells them
that's how you're supposed to perceive
it so if you see a young lady dressed
inappropriately and to your child you
make the gesture would you like mommy to
wear that the child would be like oh
that feels awkward so before you slam
God's law on someone just go with the
natural inclination and you'll find that
that inclination was clarified in the
Quran and that inclination was there
we're gonna be right back with more here
the D show don't go nowhere do you think
these things are gonna bring you
happiness
you know why you keep going back to the
club and you keep going back to these
desires because you never find
satisfaction it's going to end up
causing you if it hasn't already a lot
of pain what we are offering in Islam
what we have found in Islam for
ourselves is a means by which our hearts
aren't pleased they're at rest they're
not discontent we are pleased with what
we have
those who do I am Not Afraid to stand
alone if allies by my side I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand alone if a box by my side I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand alone good for box by my side I am
not afraid to stay
back here on the DS show we're talking
about summer fun and the woman who's
decided that you know what I don't want
to be used and abused I don't like these
men staring at me googly-eye she's
secure and she don't want all that
negative attention she wants attention
from her create or so she decided not to
take the fashion from Beyonce or Britney
Spears she's taken the fashion from the
one who created creation and sent the
fashion down and she is covering herself
the organic way the right way the way
that the crater told her to cover so
she's covering up so and she's not
giving up yes but now the outside people
are like man this woman's to extreme you
got the woman it's winter and she's in a
skirt freeze enough should I wish I
could take off more now summers come
around and she's just taking it all off
she's not happy but the Muslim woman the
woman who submitted to the one creator
she's happy the other people think she's
not that her husband's making her do
this yeah it's forcing this honor we're
in America brother free country free
choice she made the choice what about
this misconception and the tip for the
Muslim woman to keep strong subhanAllah
a very juicy question let's just start
at the top every time you see any
depiction of the Virgin Mary she has a
cloth on her head right she said the
covering of the head for a woman and the
the shawl coming over her bosom this is
from the beginning of time
but my question is to every viewer who
sees a Muslim girl we see girls who
cover their face it's called niqab we
see girls who wear hijab and they're
just girls who dress loosely and the
first question is aren't you HOT that in
itself means you're looking at them and
you're perceiving that they're hot right
you're looking at them and you're
perceiving oh she must be hot why not
ask why not say hey all these women
around the world are covering themselves
maybe your body temperature does get
used to it and it does you do get used
to it but what we want people to
understand is hijab the covering of the
head or even the loose-fitting clothing
it's a choice it's a choice that women
make and it makes them feel more
comfortable about themselves best
example when you see the supermodel
modeling in the mirror and
kind of grabs a little bit because it's
skin right but you'll never be perfect
so the more you keep uncovering you
start realizing okay I tighten this up I
can do this and there are extreme
procedures people go through but why not
be content now let's go into the second
phase fashion islam's loves fashion the
Prophet peace be upon him
mentioned that when you make your
prayers to adorn beautiful clothes and
when you when you rise and take a fresh
shower and you present yourself to God
and you make prayers it cleanses
yourself what we're asking people to
think about is be completely fashionable
and accessorize and look gorgeous but
when you come out into this society just
because you come out to society for a
reason for school for shopping you draw
a small cloak over yourself that
indicates the people around you you know
what I mean business I'm a respectful
person you can talk to me you can engage
here but everything that it that is me
it's gonna be covered and you're just
gonna experience what it is that God
intended my face so I think when you see
a hijab' woman try to keep a woman who
covers her head try to keep pictures of
the Virgin Mary in your head or pictures
of the mother Teresa or any Muslim woman
Yvonne Ridley who came back from
Afghanistan there's so many women who
are covered and happy there are women
surfers there's the burqini they're a
hundred ways that we can look at this
but why put my opinion that a girl
doesn't a girl should be uncovered why
do I force that on someone else because
I think her husband is forcing her
because Hollywood told me that Arabs and
Muslims are mean to men
why not engage in some real conversation
now the the not yet Muslim and because
everyone has I've said this so many
times because our viewing audience are
our brothers in humanity yes sir but we
want them to be our brothers and sisters
in faith and that just acknowledging
what's in your very nature that there's
only one God
he's not a man or woman but he's the
creator man and woman and we want to
live according to his plan not our plan
and that's just called a human being -
good - good things to do good to be good
so we can end up in the best place
paradise my next question so the person
is acknowledging as they watch them deed
shows and said man just making sense you
know what I mean I'm not talking about
worshipping you know a messenger a saint
or anything in creation I want to
worship God I want to do good now
it's the question about hijab okay she's
there and she's like well you know I'm
being more modest you know I'm not
revealing the shape of my body you know
tight clothes so it's loose she's having
a little bit a hard time with the
commitment with hijab but she says man
look I'm a little more modest so you
have these sisters they're wearing it
here they got the hijab but everything
else is sticking out so what is your
suggestion for those now that just keep
it real you know we keep it real here to
see on a TV show for the for the bang
jobbies and the whole jobbies you know
what but we try to get real hijab ease
right give the advice please for all our
Muslim you and I just look I didn't call
him that there's an actual phrase they
call themselves whole jobbies and bang
job you so we didn't coin this turn it's
an actual Facebook page so it's a it's a
Facebook page so we're just trying to
give the the loving advice talk to us so
loving advice to those who in the Muslim
community who want to look sexy but
still want to wear hijab it's something
that's forced down your throat from Glee
to Gilmore Girls you have to look hot
but you still have to draw your veil
first to the girls who or to the people
who don't dress modestly this could be
guys or girls who make excuse and say I
have a clean heart for them it's my
suggestion it's my thought and a caring
word don't make excuses for what someone
else is doing incorrectly what I say is
try it I gave an example and a shattered
a lot of people's comfort levels but you
know the whole Trayvon hood thing people
are wearing hoods a congressmen wore a
hood in in the assembly and was asked to
be to leave
I encourage young people who need the
push don't do it for Trayvon but put a
hijab or dress modestly stop wearing
such tight clothing and when someone
says hey you look different
like hey trying to represent you could
make up a funny excuse as its it's like
an analogy you can be like oh it's like
the Trayvon thing I'm just trying to
dress confidently this gives us an
excuse to get around because we worry
about what people say the last and most
important thing is I mean this with all
due respect to my to my sisters
I don't grow up knowing that it's I'm
not growing up saying that it's easy to
wear
job in America but I am saying this much
if you're gonna put the cloak on your
head then match the part if I'm gonna
wear a baseball cap sideways covering
one eyebrow and I have a chain I ain't
gonna walk around with it in a suit with
a handkerchief right I'm gonna play the
part so if you're choosing to make this
affectionate connection with your
Creator that this is yours you look to
your Creator and say this is yours I'm
gonna cover it and when you allow me to
meet someone that I love then I will
share that with them so that's my advice
to everyone at home having that trouble
take the leap try it and keep your
intention for God and please try to make
modesty something more than a cloth on
your head and we all know what that
means the hijab is not the cloth on the
head it's Ahmad which is something that
comes over your head and covers your
neck and your bosoms and also it doesn't
indicate that you have legs we have to
we're being real right absolutely we got
to keep it real no no they're not
exactly the most beautiful creatures in
the world right but a woman could a
woman carries that honor
let's treasure that honor in a box in a
behind a veil or within the confines of
modesty and at the end of the day this
is just advice from a brother from a
friend there was a beautiful display
when someone asked why two year most
your Muslim woman cover and instead of
just going off and talking talking the
man gave a beautiful example he took two
pieces of candy open one up throw it on
the floor and said which one would you
take you know the story I'm hearing and
then he put he said I'll take the one
that's wrapped up covered right because
the beautiful things are covered there
deep down are the corals and pearls and
you had a wonderful thing and even
treasures and treasures and diamonds and
castles it's always even the Ferrari key
when you buy a brand new all right it
comes in a book comes in a box it's
amazing when you go down we can go on
and on all the expensive gems and jewels
they don't leave it on this place we're
gonna snatch it and grab it but then
they're being told at home that I'm not
physical I'm not a material thing no but
women are treasure treasure they are
beyond they are the princesses of the
home and if you treated an empress and
her you never see the queen or the
Empress trotting around and whatever she
wants she's always dignified and that's
what Islam wants to do is to give honor
not just to men and
to women but to our society and it might
not make sense in the beginning because
folks because Lady Gaga wore meat she
would made a meat dress and she said I
don't want to be looked at as a piece of
meat of course you're gonna stick out so
why not cover why not
instead of making these huge statements
and wearing meat why don't we just cover
ourselves and treat ourselves like human
beings and have interactions up here not
down here
exactly exactly we'll be right back with
more on this exciting show summer fun
how to keep it fun the wholesome way
would be right back
when people say that the Quran is
irrelevant I say how can we become
irrelevant Obama reign is just like
revelation the Koran is a living book
it's not a dead book it's not an ancient
book it's a living book for all time
because God knows the past and the
future and so it's up to us as Muslims
to take the verses of the Koran the
values in the principle of the Koran and
to relate them to finding solutions for
contemporary issues and circumstances
back here on the Deen show and we're
almost out of time and I'm very excited
I'm sure the people are excited and
we're giving them enough that they can
ponder reflect over before that moment
and look I'm not trying to ruin your
mood now but we're gonna die there's a
paradise as a Hellfire don't sleep now
wake up now so you can live how the
crater wants you to live so you can get
paradise yes sir because we're gonna be
accountable right so how could someone
know that this is right just in brief
how can someone because all these
religions out there people like I don't
want to follow an organized religion
false science my brain my logic use your
brain to come to this truth because it
provides the proof but how could someone
know that this is the truth from the
crater before they submit to this way of
life first step the fact that the
manuscripts stayed true the Quran has
never changed it wasn't written by
someone so the foundation of the
religion it's not there in any other
religion right now let's move away from
the word religion and let's say it's not
just a spiritual set of laws but Islam
the Deen the way of life also tells us
how to live the key factor that you
would know to make a a commitment or an
addition to your belief the key factor
is that Islam that came from our
creator Allah it fulfills the need to
get married it fulfills the need of how
to do business it fulfills the need of
social economic of national and
international treaties how could a book
632 pages carry that so if someone
wanted to make a commitment today and
they feel the inclination like I know
that there's one God Jesus Moses Abraham
okay I can believe in Mohammed too if
they're ready to make that commitment
then the biggest step is to read or on
and those who are not there I encourage
them to open the book read it
cover-to-cover we've read 18 page 18
hundred pages of Harry Potter so we can
read a few words a few chapters out of
the Quran or maybe hear a small youtube
clip on it the reason why people should
submit to it is because there is no god
but God there's no creator but one
creator and if there were multiple
creators we'd have chaos and that God
communicates with us through prophets
I'm sorry going God create communicates
through us through prophets and that is
the solidifying chain that we have
between us and God and that's what it's
long as don't take a chance because when
you die and then it's in front of you
the Angel of Death takes your soul and
now the day of judgment doesn't make
sense you're gonna do everything rain
havoc on earth and at the end just like
in the movie we're waiting for the
criminal to get justice served on him
you're gonna go and do all these evil
things and not even acknowledge that
there's one who created you and think
that you're not gonna be accountable
does it make sense does it make sense go
on the gamble go on the gamble ten
thousand years of prophethood gave one
message there's one God and ten thousand
years of prophethood had one message and
now man has written books perverted laws
made-up ideologies social systems on
their own are you gonna go with these
ten thousand years of one message or
you're gonna say well man figured it out
and religion is the opiate for the
masses these little phrases that throw
us off a system that how about we take
one ayah from the Quran please this is
your answer to why should I understand
God says in surah number 67
Allah Allah woman call out alas would
not the one who created no or lovely for
Cobb you that that's your key phrase
there when I tell you to wear hijab you
might be like hey why we Sam why are you
telling me but when we say
hey this is what God likes better and I
can verify this book is from God that's
why I would believe now the brothers
also they're on the hunt a lot of times
and we know that this is a major sin and
in summertime it seems like the more
that's coming off now them with the
desires are heating up and the brothers
we know and women should be lowering
their gaze to protect themselves we all
get caught off and we slip up sometimes
you know we look at something but it's I
got arrow through the heart it creates
that rust and it gives you that ill
feeling so we don't want that and we
want to let the sisters know that don't
get caught in the hustle with the
beautiful lyrics that a brother who's
maybe not god-fearing he shouldn't be
chasing something outside of mirror she
shouldn't be nyeeehhh because if he's
going back door not front door through
the proper channels he don't want
nothing but from you but to think of
that enjoy you so let's give advice
because this is the summertime blam it
by blasting the car radio picking up the
girls so some some some advice on this
issue I know it's short but what do you
say for Friday for this summer all
Muslims and those who maybe don't pray
one of the biggest things is when you
experience these five four or five
minutes a day of prayer in a slot that
then huh I mean fashio that the prayer
is gonna move us away from a lewdness
and perverseness perversity what I would
like to say though for the young people
for this summer is women have the
control because they have a treasure so
the more that you cover and someone asks
but why are you dressed like this the
simple word it's because God wants me to
be modest or to say the word modest I
promise our viewers that I've been to
middle schools and elementary schools
around the United States and there were
a few places where the teacher said
modesty ten hands went up what does that
mean the words not used anymore so I
encourage people to use the word any and
just say say it to other people in the
society it's like a it's a good word it
spreads lastly those two guys guys we
know that it's in our control it's in
our control as much as we say to a
female and how we interact with them
when we lower our gaze we respect and
dignify that woman but the thing that I
want to it's my warning to myself not to
anyone
else those little arrows that come into
your heart every time you see a little
bit of a dirty scene or every time you
hear something inappropriate they won't
hurt after a while because if you take
one spot and you keep stabbing it after
a while it dies and that's what I'm
encouraging young people today it might
just seem like one bad show
it might just seem like I'm only talking
to one person on Facebook my status is
in a relationship but eventually when
you learn to change your socks
constantly a relationship will become
just like a piece of clothing yeah it
didn't work out and you moved on so I
encourage everyone to find that balance
because the rust on the heart the effect
of sin on in our life it does take a
toll but we don't see it till it's
rusted and when something is rusted it's
very hard to to clean that off so let's
let's put some pre-emptive take some
pre-emptive measures not to get this
rust to keep our eyes safe to keep our
tongue safe most importantly keep
between what is between your lips safe
and guard about is between your legs
this is a statement of Abu Bakr al
al-amin before we leave give us
something that they can hear let them
hear the verbatim Word of God
maybe I took Chrissy kick can you and
just define it real quick I mean not to
rush your night and then give the
website where people can go your website
to learn Quran let us hear these
beautiful words of from the verbatim
word of that from the most loving
merciful creator from the Quran please
surah fatiha this is the opening chapter
the verse that my good friend is talking
about it's 255 that is it-- of course
it's a little bit lengthy so surah
fatiha you can listen to this you can
play this back if you feel sick anxiety
anxiety listen to this alhamdulillah he
won't be long I mean all praise and
thanks are due to God the creator of all
nations the god of all nations rahmani
raheem the most beneficent the most
merciful so whether you praise him or
not God is still merciful Malik you mean
the owner of the day of judgment whether
you believe in deaths has a doorway
passing to another world or you're you
believe in death immediately you are
going to meet your Creator so yankin our
Buddha ye
kind of styrene I know I'm gonna meet
him so you alone do I worship God and
you alone do I ask for help you know
sleep all while must LTE what kind of
help can I ask I can ask for guidance
consistent straight guidance I don't
want the printed out a MapQuest I want
the GPS I want it to be I want God God's
guidance to be with me constantly
Slovenian on Donaghy hidden like guide
me to that path of the people whom you
have favoured the people who are on your
good side
levena an entirely hidden little malulu
VRA him what a Waleed but don't make me
amongst those who kind of taunt at God's
laws who earn his anger by saying so you
want me to do this or this or this and
constantly question and please save me
from the path of those who went astray
they might have had good intentions and
it started out in the right place but
they took a long turn at Albuquerque
they took a wrong turn along the path
maybe they made a profit into a god or
they made a profit sin there are a lot
of stories like this so we do our best
to be guided and to be amongst those who
find ease may God have peace and
blessings upon you this evening this
afternoon this is sort of Fatiha the
opening of Quran this is a beautiful
wonderful way to end we wouldn't have it
no other way el hamdulillah what's your
website where people can hear more of
you get in contact with you sure it's
learn to read Quran calm in short it's
l2 r q calm it's a site to help you
learn the Arabic alphabet to recite
surah fatiha what we just did here and I
hope that it provides some benefit to
the community Allah give you dinner
no it's good it's good with them and let
it let it be namdong and that's what
LaRon does just Alcala hi - may Allah
rewards you bless you and inshallah
we'll meet again I hope so thank you for
having me on the show it's a great
pleasure likewise thank you and that was
another exciting episode here on the
Deen show you got to hear the verbatim
literal word of the creator of the
heavens and earth you might have not
understood it but he even gave you the
explanation the translation so you got
to hear it understand it somewhat and if
you're sincere with yourself that truth
will penetrate the heart and you'll
continue to reflect on what the purpose
of life is why you're here in this world
where you're going when you die the
curve and answers all those questions
and more give us a call if you'd like to
learn more about the Quran get it for
free 1 800 662 Islam and continue to
tune in here to the D show stay safe
stay looking ahead to paradise for Jenna
and the only way you can get there is by
submitting yourself entirely to the one
who created you doing good being good
and staying away from all those things
that's displeased the crater so you can
please him and be with him in paradise
we'll see you next time here on the Deen
show peace be with you